This video is brought to you by war thunder.
What's up wisecrack Jared here. I'm not sure if you've noticed a trend lately,
but a lot of very smart people are acting incredibly dumb.
Elon Musk made some very bold and very wrong statements about Corona virus.
Musical genius.
Kanye West has announced a run for president without even filing the right
paperwork.
And I can't seem to go a day without finding out some award-winning scientists
Hawking weird pseudoscience.
Professor Milton is first of all, a medical doctor,
a pragmatist he's convinced that water memory opens a new area of
research for medicine.
The hate on Musk or Kanye one is in my humble opinion, a musical genius,
and the other changed the landscape of cars with Tesla.
But what if some of the weirder antics of people like Musk,
aren't just regular human error,
but speak to a bigger problem about how we understand intelligence.
In other words, why do geniuses act so dumb?
Welcome this wisecrack addition on the myth of genius and no spoilers ahead,
but before we continue, I want to give a shout out to this week.
Sponsor war thunder from the makers of cross-out and star conflict comes war
thunder, a free large-scale combat MMO. That's available on PCPs four,
and X-Box one in the game.
You can fight in history's most iconic battles by air, land, or sea.
Take your TA on a world tour and shoot down some helicopters or send a massive
cruiser to the bottom of the sea. With war fenders, high-end graphics.
It's like being in the middle of history.
There are more than 1500 combat vehicles and over 350 unique airplanes to
choose from the flight. Sam is one of my favorite parts.
Since they spare no detail in what it's like to fly a plane,
you can customize your vehicles with upgrades, mods, and even custom skins.
Then once you're ready, you can choose a battle from world war II, the cold war,
or a modern conflict anywhere on the globe.
War thunder is always updating the game.
So there's always something new to explore.
You can download the game today for free by using the link in the description.
When you download the game, using our link,
you'll get some awesome bonuses that guarantee some wins at the get-go.
So download the game today,
and now back to the show to really understand the strange paradox of genius.
I want to tell you the story of Linus Pauling board at the beginning of the 20th
century, Linus Pauling was a Titan of science in his thirties.
He proposed a third way. Adams could bind together called orbital hybridization.
He then went on to identify several key features of DNA structure,
created a formula to measure electronegativity and discovered the underlying
mechanism behind sickle cell anemia for all his work.
Pauling has the distinction of being only one of four people in history to win
two Nobel prizes though. One was a peace prize.
So if anyone gets the genius title it's Pauling, right? Well,
maybe not. Palling made another contribution to science, ortho,
molecular medicine, going to by Pauling in the late sixties,
the term refers to the practice of treating everything from the common cold to
psychosis, to cancer,
to even AIDS with vitamins taken at high mega doses.
Now, I don't think it takes a genius to know that vitamins won't cure cancer,
but at the time this idea gained some major traction after all one of the
smartest scientists alive was not only advocating for it,
but even publishing multiple books about it,
but the wider scientific and medical community wasn't buying it.
The American psychiatric association, for example,
wrote a blistering report in 1973,
questioning why Pauling's vitamin of choice.
Niacin seemed to never provide the results he claimed when experiments were
performed by independent investigators.
The APH major concern was that his claims were at best unprovable and at worst
dangerous,
despite them calling the practice and its claims deplorable and the American
Academy of pediatrics calling it a cult,
Linus Pauling only doubled down until he died in 1994 after his death in
1996 study on the effects of vitamin a and beta carotene on heavy smokers had to
be cut short after lung cancer rates soared 28% and the mortality rate Rose a
horrifying 17% among the participants.
All of which raises the very simple question,
how did one of the world's smartest men end up being so dumb and why do we
continue to worship him? In spite of this,
even catapulting his pseudoscience to the New York times bestseller list,
as it turns out, the idea of genius is modern concept.
The Latin word genius originally referred to an individual spirit that inhabits
and protects a person from their birth thereby determining their character,
which isn't that surprising when you consider the Latin root of genius is Gignac
or to Perth or beget.
So when you grew up to be a tough as nails general or a talented Bard ancient
Romans would chalk up your talents to your individual genius.
And there's a certain appeal to this.
This Roman sense of the word can explain why someone excels in a certain area
without committing us to believe they're great at everything.
Using the sense of the word.
We can immediately see the problem with Linus Pauling.
The guy was a brilliant chemist and a biologist looking at the proteins of
misshapen blood cells, but not exactly a shoe in for cancer doctor of the year.
It wasn't until the 16 hundreds that our modern notion of genius started to
emerge.
The word began to refer to a specific individual with a natural intelligence or
talent and exalted natural mental ability. And this is where the problem starts,
where genius begins to gain the revered catch all status. It has today,
who words evolving definition corresponds with the larger cultural shift of the
European enlightenment.
This was a time of unparalleled intellectual growth in Western Europe,
manifesting everything from the birth of modern science to the creation of
calculus, astronomy,
and economics central to all this intellectual progress though,
was the idea that man could through his intellect,
unlock the keys to the universe and change our world for the better.
This is around when we start to see glimmers of our modern day genius, warship,
18th century, French philosopher, and Roberto Dr. Go for example,
asserted that progress only occurs when an individual genius makes advances in
their field. According to [inaudible] state tab,
the responsibility to foster these geniuses and allow them to flourish in his
eyes.
There probably wouldn't be anything wrong with government Tesla or solar city
through lucrative tax credits or giving Conway's fashion brand Yeezy,
a small business loan in the wake of COVID-19 it's all in the service of further
developing their genius, 19th century, Scottish philosopher and mathematician.
Thomas Carlisle takes this idea of war shipping geniuses.
One step further in his book on heroes,
hero worship and the heroic and history Carlisle famously stated that the
history of the world is, but the biography of great men in Carlyle's view,
a select few geniuses were responsible for all the major developments throughout
history. While us lay people were just along for the ride. After all history,
won't remember the original founders of Tesla, engineers, Martin Eberhard,
and Mark tarponing much less credit the countless other designers or technicians
who have worked towards the company success, but we won't forget Elon Musk,
American philosopher, Sidney hook,
perhaps the best encapsulates this perspective,
arguing that genius is not the result of compounding talent.
How many battalions are the equivalent of a Napoleon?
How many minor poets will give us the Shakespeare?
How many run of the mill scientists will do the work of an Einstein,
but even though they lauded geniuses,
they still distinguish between different kinds of geniuses. Thomas Carlisle,
for example, divided it as great men into six categories. He wouldn't,
for example,
compared the genius of a priest like Martin Luther to that of a poet like John
Milton,
similarly Francis Galton the father of the sense extremely debunked theory of
eugenics broke down. These star-studded world of geniuses into categories,
ranging from judges and statesman to scientists, painters, poets,
and even oarsmen now golden and Carlisle.
Aren't exactly the standard for today's scientific exploration of genius.
But if you want to look at the world of smart people saying dumb things,
a pretty good red flag is people venturing outside of their speciality.
That isn't to say that multi-platinum artist Kanye West isn't allowed to have
political opinions or that scientists haven't excelled in multiple fields,
but in today's world of hyper specialized knowledge,
nothing about understanding how jet propulsion works makes one,
an expert on epidemiology.
Nowhere is this more apparent than when you venture into the world of
pseudo-science there you'll see a crop of PhDs and MDs venturing outside of
their speciality claiming to be some revolutionary thinker,
despite their lack of training or peer reviewed publications on the topic. Take,
for example,
someone like [inaudible] who despite being awarded a Nobel prize for proving
electron tunneling occurs in super doctors also happens to be among the biggest
climate change deniers in the scientific community. On the one hand,
a genius on the other, the dumdum there's also just people who go off the rails,
take Luke Monterey,
who proved that a retrovirus causes AIDS only to turn around and publish two
papers claiming that DNA can produce electromagnetic signals when diluted AKA
basically homeopathy Monte AEs claims were met with scorn from the scientific
community, but this is only half the story.
There's another reason modern society,
valorizes geniuses like Albert Einstein or Elon Musk,
presuming them to somehow have special brain's capable of tackling any problem
regardless of the time,
which brings us to IQ cast your mind back to the French countryside in the early
20th century, universal education has just become a thing.
And as your classroom is flooded with children from all sorts of backgrounds,
you need to identify which ones have special education needs so they can get
extra attention. How do you do this? Well, if your psychologist,
Alfred Benet and his assistant Theodore Simon,
you decide to test each child to determine what their mental age is a child who
could answer all the questions expected of a typical eight year old would be
said to have the mental age of eight.
But if the next eight year old could answer the questions for a typical
nine-year-old, they'd have a mental age of nine.
Now it's important to note that Benet didn't think this number could fully
quantify a child's intellectual capacity or potential weirdly that it could
predict how a child would perform in school at that point in time,
just because a young Linus Pauling guilty chemistry lab from scratch and likely
had a higher mental age than his peers wouldn't in Bearnaise mind mean that the
other kids couldn't catch up. Even though Benet,
wasn't trying to quantify genius.
Two psychologists independently took Bernay's model and tried to do just that.
The first was Lewis Terman.
If Benet was against the idea of ranking people by intelligence,
Terman was all for it,
inspired by Golden's theory of hereditary genius and Bearnaise mental ages.
Terman decided he was going to scientifically quantify intelligence to do so.
He applied a simple formula mental age divided by physical age times a hundred
equals intelligence quotient or IQ.
So if you can answer a question that a 10 year old can, and you're only five,
10 divided by five is two times a hundred is 200.
You're a genius with this simple calculus termin instituted the modern regime of
IQ testing. As we know it today,
ranking and sorting everyone from school students to army recruits,
but this massive wave of testing brought to light and interesting fact as
English psychologist,
Charles Spearman first noted scores across different portions of different IQ
tests were positively correlated. In other words,
kids who were good at pattern recognition, for example,
we're also good at vocabulary and memorization intelligence.
It would seem wasn't tied to specific subjects or areas. Instead,
this statistical correlation implied what Spearman called general intelligence,
better known as G. We now had a modern conception of genius.
A genius was someone with a high IQ,
which made you smart about almost everything in committing to this view. We,
as a society had completed a U-turn on our pre enlightenment views.
Amos was no longer something that everyone possessed a characteristic or quirk
to explain their personality instead it's the domain of the hyper-intelligent
and we should Revere them for it.
So don't criticize Elon Musk for dipping his toes into predictive modeling.
And COVID-19 even if he's catastrophic the wrong and don't,
you dare think that Hawking vitamins is a cure for cancer is essentially a
multi-level marketing scheme with less steps.
We often give these people the benefit of the doubt,
just because they're seemingly much smarter than us,
or at least that's what the cultural narrative wants us to do.
It's the reason why Albert Einstein with zero political experience was offered
the presidency of Israel in 1952, because he's just so smart.
But Einstein understanding that his genius was not universal declined,
citing his complete and utter lack of experience in the matter.
And here's where we can understand how termin and Spearman got a lot about
intelligence law, despite its prominence in popular culture,
the IQ test and the concept of monolithic G has been under sustained attack
from psychologists for decades. The problem is that intelligence tests,
whether they're dealing with logical or spatial reasoning are only measuring
intelligence and a certain sense.
It's hard to see how an IQ test will spot the person who's going to make the
next big contribution to music or how a kid with impeccable spatial reasoning
will do in the floor is lava. According to psychologist, Robert Sternberg,
this is where most intelligence tests fail there,
refuse to look into the context of what they measure in Sternberg's view.
We're suffering from predictor criteria and confusion.
That's a fancy way of saying we're using IQ tests to reflect intelligence more
than real world problem solving to Sternberg intelligence has to take into
account the purpose of adaptation to shaping of,
and selection of real-world environments relevant to one's life. In other words,
intelligence doesn't occur in a vacuum.
Instead what's considered intelligence changes drastically between cultures,
environments, and situations.
While being able to spend hundreds of hours studying for the sat might make you
smart by ecologist standard for a Hunter gatherer intelligence might be linked
to the ability to orient yourself and your surroundings while tracking prey.
In both cases,
our intelligent human is adapting to real life scenarios to get what they want.
Even if these forms of intelligence are very different. Going back to Canada,
the only way to measure his specific brilliance is to hear his music.
So here's the big question. Wisecrack,
if our modern conception of genius rests on IQ tests that are kind of bunk and a
concept of gee,
that might not really mean anything in a broader sense of intelligence,
is there really even such a thing as a genius at all? Sure.
Elon Musk has had moments of genius as did Linus Pauling before him.
But what if they're actually just smart people who happened to stumble upon some
breakthrough ideas, as it turns out there's some evidence.
This might be the case Terman in his quest for studying geniuses actually
embarked on one of the longest running longitudinal studies in history,
partnering with the California public school system.
He used IQ test to identify the most gifted children and then followed up with
them for the next 35 years while Turman hoped to find the great men that
Carlisle theorized moved history. Instead,
most of his approximately 1500 geniuses went on to live normal lives in
a devastating analysis sociologist.
Peter M Sorkin demonstrated the Turmans geniuses did just as well in life as a
random sampling of kids from a similar socioeconomic status. In other words,
genius level IQ didn't produce any Linus Pauling's or Elon Musk's. In fact,
as journalist Malcolm Gladwell points out termin actually tested and ultimately
rejected two individuals who went on to win Nobel prizes, maybe genius,
isn't a number then, or rather the happy accident of a hardworking, lucky,
and ultimately normal person.
And maybe they get a boost from specific kinds of reasoning skills,
Terence Tao the winner of the field's medal in 2006,
kind of like the Nobel prize for math except much more exclusive takes just this
view.
He argues the popular image of the loan and possibly slightly mad genius who
ignores the literature and other conventional wisdom and manages by some
inexplicably inspiration to come up with a breathtakingly original solution to a
problem that confounded all the experts is a charming and romantic image,
but also a wildly inaccurate one to toe genius.
Isn't the result of the great men that Carlisle proposed. Instead,
the genius stands as hop the shoulders of those that came before who small
incremental advances led to the geniuses breakthrough. It's not brilliant.
It's simply progress obtained naturally and cumulatively as a consequence of
hard work directed by intuition literature and a bit of luck.
But what do you think wise crack did the simulation just short us,
the intelligence needed to fully appreciate the legend that is Elon Musk.
Let us know in the comments,
how smart or dumb you think we are for writing this.
Thanks to all our awesome patrons for supporting the channel and our podcasts
slam that subscribe button to prove how smart you are or don't. And as always,
thanks for watching guys.
[Inaudible].